in this lecture we introduced Markov
chains virginal plus of random processes
with many applications dealing with the
evolution of dynamical systems they have
been used in physics chemistry
information sciences queueing theory
internet applications statistics finance
games music genetics baseball history
you name it so what make these processes
so powerful and practical well as
opposed to their newly and Poisson
processes which are memory less in the
sense that the future does not depend on
the past Markov chains are more
elaborate as they allow the
representation of situations where the
future depend on the past and to some
extent could be predicted from the past
more precisely we are going to consider
malls where the influence of the past
and the future is summarized by the
notion of a state which evolves over
time according to some probability
distribution that's the link between the
past and the future we will restrict
ourselves to discrete time Markov chains
in which the state changes that certain
discrete time steps to state at time T
plus one which is here is a function of
the state at time T and there is some
noise of randomness as an overview this
is what we will cover in this lecture we
will first introduce the basic concepts
using the example of a checkout counter
at the supermarket will then abstract
from the example and give some general
definitions afterwards we will look at
various questions such as predicting
what could happen in the future given
the current state of our systems we will
end this lecture by giving some key
structural properties of Markov
processes so let us start